well King Alex 178 is a student in high
school and he asked the following
question what could I do to support the
economy of my country I think that's a
terrific question because you are in the
frame of mind which is positive where
you want to contribute you're not asking
what you know the country can do for you
what you're saying what could I do and
my response to your question is you
should study hard you should learn as
much as you can you should educate
yourself through the globe as much
training as you can and you should share
that enthusiasm for learning for
training for understanding the world
better and for being able later on to
participate as a citizen as an economic
actor as well in developing growth and
more importantly in innovating because
we need innovators we need young
students to today believe that tomorrow
will be better and that they will be the
innovators of tomorrow